Ok, roll it.
You know what this is? It is the longest word
in the world.
Like, anywhere, in any language, ever.
More than 189,000 letters.
If you were to write it down, though I don't
know why you would, it'd fill up more than
100 pages!
And if you could actually say it without,
like, breaking your face, it'd take about
FIVE hours!
So what the frick is this word?
It's the name of the longest known protein
on earth. And it's actually in you right now.
Because of its enormous size, it was given
the nickname Titin by scientists.
And that's with two i's.
It's a protein that helps give some of the
springiness to your muscles.
Today we're going to be talking about DNA
and how it, along with three versions of its
cousin RNA, unleash chemical kung fu to synthesize proteins just like this.
This is going to take a while to explain,
so how about if we make ourselves some hot pockets.
Mmmm, my favorite. Ham and cheese.
Every time I take a bite I wonder, how do
they do it?
How do they pack exactly the same flavor into
every foil-cardboard wrapped foodish item?
Clearly there has got to be some super secret
instruction manual kept in a location known
to only two people.
And since I'm talking about biology here,
that brings up a related question:
How did I get built from the DNA instructions
and biological molecules we've been talking about?
Today, that's what I'm going to do. Not
actually make hot pockets, or a person.
But I'm going to be talking about DNA transcription
and translation
which is how we get made into the delicious
things we are today.
Though hopefully none of us know how delicious
people are.
Animals, plants, and hot pockets are really
nothing more than salty water, carbohydrates,
fats, and protein, combined in precise proportions
following very explicit instructions.
Let's say I want to make my own hot pocket.
I would have to:
1) break into the lair of the Hot Pocket Company
holding the secret manual
2) read the instructions on how to make the
machinery to produce the hot pocket and the
proportions of the ingredients
3) quickly write down that information in
shorthand before I get caught by the hot pocket police
4) go home and follow the instructions to
build the machinery and mix the ingredients
until I have a perfect hot pocket.
That's how we get us.
Very simply, inside a cell's nucleus, the
DNA instruction manual is copied gene by gene
by transcription onto a kind of RNA
then taken out of the lair where the instructions
are followed, by the process of translation
to assemble amino acid strings into polypeptides
or proteins that make up all kinds of stuff
from this titin down here to the keratin in
my hair.
But most of the polypeptides that get made
aren't structural proteins like hair, they're enzymes
which go on to act like the assembly machinery,
breaking down and building and combining carbohydrates
and lipids and proteins that make up variations
of cell material.
So enzymes are just like whatever ingenious
machinery 'they' use at the factory to make this.
Let's start in the lair -- I mean the nucleus.
The length of DNA that we're going to transcribe
onto an RNA molecule is called our transcription unit.
Let's say, in today's example, that it's
going to include the gene that transcribes
for our friend titin
which, in humans at least,
occurs on Chromosome 2.
Now each transcription unit has a sequence
just above it in the strand
and that's called "upstream"
biologists call that "upstream" on the strand
And that sequence defines where the transcription
unit is going to begin.
This special sequence is the promoter, and
it almost always contains a sequence of two
of the four nitrogenous bases we discussed
in our last episode: adenine (A), thymine (T)
cytosine (C) and guanine (G).
Specifically, the promoter is a really simple
repetition
we've got thymine, adenine, thymine, adenine,
and then A-A-A.
And on the other side: ATATTTT. Because you
know how this works, right!?
This is called the TATA box. It's nearly universal
and helps our enzyme figure out where to bind to the strand.
Now, you'll remember from our episode about
DNA structure that DNA strands run in one
of two directions
depending on which end of the strand is free
and which end has a phosphate bond.
One direction is 5 prime-3 prime, and the
other is 3 prime-5 prime.
In this case, upstream means toward the 3
prime end and downstream means toward 5 prime.
So the first enzyme in this process is RNA
polymerase, and it copies the DNA sequence
downstream of the TATA box
that's towards the 5' end and copies it into a
similar type of language: messenger RNA [mRNA].
Quick aside: So you'll notice that to read
the DNA in order to make enzymes we need an
enzyme in the first place.
So it kind of gets "chicken vs egg" here.
We need the enzyme to make the DNA and the
DNA to make the enzyme.
So, where did RNA polymerase come from if
we haven't made it yet!?
What an excellent question! It turns out all of these
basic necessities get handed down from your Mom.
She packed quite a bit more into her egg cell
than just her DNA so we had a healthy start.
So, thanks Mom!
So the RNA polymerase binds to the DNA at
that TATA box, and begins to unzip the double-helix.
Working along the DNA chain, the enzyme reads
the nitrogenous bases, those are the letters
and helps the RNA version of the nitrogenous
bases floating around in the nucleus find their match.
Now as you ALSO might recall from our previous
episode
nitrogenous bases only have one counterpart
that they can bond with.
But RNA, which is the pink one here, doesn't
have thymine like DNA does
which is the green and the blue.
Instead it has uracil (U), so U appears here
in T's place as the partner to adenine.
As it moves, the RNA polymerase re-zips the
DNA behind it and lets our new strand of messenger
RNA peel away.
Eventually, the RNA polymerase reaches another
sequence downstream, called a termination
signal, that triggers it to pull off.
Now, some finishing touches before this info
can safely leave the lair.
First, a special type of guanine (G) is added
to the 5-prime end
that's the first part of the mRNA we copied
and this is called the 5' cap.
On the other end, it looks like I fell asleep
with my finger on the A key of my keyboard
but another enzyme added about 250 adenines
on the 3' end.
This is called the poly-A tail.
These caps on either end of the RNA package
make it easier for the mRNA to leave the nucleus
and they also help protect it from degradation
from passing enzymes, while making it easier
to connect with other organelles later on.
But that's still not the end of it. As if
to try to confuse me to protect the secret
hotpocket recipe
the original recipe book also contains lots
of extra, misleading information.
So just before leaving the nucleus, that extra
information gets cut out of the RNA in a process
called RNA splicing.
And it's. something. like. editing. this.
video.
The process is really complicated, but I just
had to tell you about two of the key players
because they have such cool names.
One, the Snurps, which are Small Nuclear RibonucleoProteins.
These are a combination of RNA and proteins,
and they recognize the sequences that signal
the start and end of the areas to be spliced.
Snurps bunch together with a bunch of other
proteins to form the spliceosome, which is
what does the actual editing
as it were, breaking the junk segments down
so their nitrogenous bases can be reused in
DNA or RNA, and sticking together the two
ends of the good stuff.
The good stuff that gets spliced together,
by the way, are called exons because they'll
eventually be expressed
the junk that gets cut out are just intervening
segments, or introns.
The material in the introns will stay in the
nucleus and get recycled.
So for instance, titin down there is thought
to have hundreds of exons when it's all said and done
probably more than 360, which may be more
than any other protein.
And it also contains the longest intron in
humans, some 17,000 base pairs long.
Man, titian! It is just a world record holder!
So now that it has been protected and refined,
the messenger RNA can now move out of the nucleus.
OK, a quick review of our Hot Pocket Mission
Impossible caper so far:
We broke into the lair containing the instructions,
we copied down those instructions in shorthand
we added some protective coatings, and then
we cut out some extra notes that we didn't need
and then we escaped back out of the lair.
Now I have to actually read the notes, make
the machinery and assemble the ingredients.
This process is called translation.
So next, rewind your memory -- or just watch
that video again -- to the episode about animal cells.
Do you remember the rough endoplasmic reticulum? I hope you do.
Those little dots on the membranes are the
ribosomes, and the processed messenger RNA
gets fed into a ribosome like a dollar bill
into a vending machine.
Ribosomes are a mixture of protein and a second
kind of RNA, called ribosomal RNA [rRNA]
and they act together as a sort of work space.
rRNA doesn't contribute any genetic information
to the process, instead it has binding sites
that allow the incoming mRNA to interact with
another special type of RNA
the third in this caper, called transfer RNA,
or tRNA.
And tRNA really might as well be called 'translation
RNA' because that's what it does
it translates from the language of nucleotides
into the language of amino acids and proteins.
On one end of the tRNA is an amino acid. On
the other end is a specific sequence of three
nitrogenous bases.
These two ends are kind of matched to each
other.
Each of the 20 amino acids that we have in
our body has its own sequence at the end.
So if the tRNA has the amino acid methionine
on one end, for instance, it can have UAC,
as the nucleotide sequence on the other.
Now it's like building a puzzle. The mRNA
slides through the ribosome.
The ribosome reads the mRNA three letters
at a time - each set called a triplet codon.
The ribosome then finds the matching piece
of the puzzle: a tRNA with three bases that
will pair with the codon sequence.
That end of the tRNA, by the way, is called
the anticodon.
Sorry for all the terminology.
YOU NEED TO KNOW IT!
And of course, by bringing in the matching
tRNA, the ribsome is also bringing in whatever
amino acid is on that tRNA.
Ok so, starting at the 5' end of the mRNA
that's fed into the ribosome, after the
5' cap, for almost every gene, you find
the nucleotide sequence AUG on the mRNA.
The ribosome finds a tRNA with the anticodon
UAC, and on the other end of that tRNA is methionine.
The mRNA, like a mile-long dollar bill, keeps
sliding into the ribosome so that the next
codon can be read, and another tRNA molecule
with the right anticodon binds on.
If the codon is UUA, the matching tRNA has
AAU on one end and Leucine on the other
and if the mRNA has AGA, the matching tRNA
has UCU on one end and Arginine on the other.
In each case that new amino acid gets connected to
the previous amino acid - starting a polypeptide chain.
Which is the beginning, the very beginning
of a protein.
But it turns out there are LOTS of different
ways to read this code.
'Cause UUA is not the only triplet that
codes for Leucine -- UUG does too!
And argenine is coded for by six different
triplets!
This is actually a good thing. It means that
we can make a few errors in copying, transcribing
and translating DNA, and we won't necessarily
change the end product.
This process continues, with the mRNA sliding
in a bit, the ribosome bringing in a tRNA
with an amino acid, that amino acid binding
to the existing chain
and on and on, sometimes for thousands of
amino acids to make a single polypeptide chain,
for example.
This whole word is basically just the names
of the amino acids in the sequence in the
order in which they occur in the protein
all 34,350 of them.
But before we can make our own hot pockets
and that string of amino acids becomes my
muscle tissue
we have some folding to do.
That's because proteins, in addition to
being hella big, can also contort into very
complex and downright lovely formations.
One key to understanding how a protein works
is to understand how it folds, and scientists
have been working for decades on computer
programs to try to figure out protein folding.
Now, the actual sequence of amino acids in
a polypeptide - what you see scrolling along
down there - is called its primary structure.
One amino acid covalently bonded to another,
and that one to another, in a single file.
But some amino acids don't like to just
hold hands with two others, they're a bit
more promiscuous than that.
The hydrogens on the main backbone of the
amino acids like to sometimes form bonds on
the side (hydrogen bonds) to the oxygens on
amino acids a few doors down.
When they do that, depending on the primary
structure, they bend and fold and twist into
a chain of spirals, called a helix.
We also find several kinked strands laying
parallel to one another, called pleated sheets.
All those hydrogen bonds in pleated sheets
are what make silk strong, for instance.
So in the end, our promiscuous amino acids
lead to wrinkled sheets. Ah-hah!
These hydrogen bonds help give polypeptides
their secondary structure.
But it doesn't end there. Remember the R groups
that define each amino acid?
Some of them are hydrophobic. Since the protein
is in the cell, which is mostly water, all
those hydrophobic groups try to hide from
the water by huddling together, and that can
bend up the chain some more.
Other R groups are hydrophilic, which if nothing
else means that they like to form hydrogen
bonds with other hydrophilic R groups.
So we get more bonding, and more bending,
and our single-file line has now taken on
a massively complex 3-D shape.
It also explains why I can fix my bed-head
by wetting my hair with water.
The water helps break some of those hydrogen
bonds in the keratin which relaxes its structure.
That way I can comb it out, and when it dries
those bonds reform and voila, perfect hair.
All of this shape caused by bonding between
R groups gives our polypeptide a tertiary structure.
So now we have a massively contorted polypeptide chain, and it actually contorts very precisely.
Sometimes, just one chain is what makes up the whole enzyme or protein.
In other proteins, like hemoglobin, several
different chains come together to from a quaternary structure.
So a quick review of structure: the sequence
is primary, the backbone hydrogen bonds forming
sheets and spirals are secondary, R group
bonds are tertiary, and the arrangement of
multiple proteins together give quaternary
structure.
These polypeptides are either structural proteins,
like this thing at the bottom here that you
can find in muscle or in my hot pocket.
They might also be enzymes, and enzymes like,
do stuff.
They can cut up biological molecules like
I do with this chef's knife, they can mix
stuff and they can put stuff together.
So from that one recipe book we got all of
the ingredients and all of the tools necessary
to make me, which is better than a hot pocket.
Would you all agree?
Now take your time with this stuff, feel free
to watch the episode a couple of times, because
next week we're going to talk about how
cells swap all of this
genetic information through reproduction.
Thank you for watching this episode.
By now, you should probably know how this
works.
You can click on any of the links over there,
and it'll take you back to that point in the
show as long as you are not watching on your
cell phone.
It doesn't work on cell phones, I apologize
for that.
Thank you to everyone who helped us put this
show together, and thank you to you, for watching it today.
If you have any questions about this episode
please leave them in the comments below, or
you can get us on Facebook or Twitter.
And that's all. Goodbye!